but the other problem is like consumer
debt
and like that's like 80 of consumer debt
is owned by women so like women aren't
like good at saving
so it's like partially like our own
fault if we're in a problem where you
have 80 like 80 like because the other
genders aren't doing it i think men are
more concentrated on like when it comes
to money management so i don't think it
depends on family as well so also like
just recently started having our own
bank accounts isn't it that a woman
couldn't open a bank account until like
shortly after
uh voting was yeah but yeah but
what does that have to do with us today
like
nothing
no no no no i'm sorry no no this is that
had nothing to do with me something that
happened in the 20s i felt like i'm like
a bank
listen at the end of the day
being a woman of color
when it comes to money and all that
we're a lot more careful about this kind
of stuff because it was 19. you know our
history does not prove well when it
comes to finances and education you know
and we're trying to work better well
it's something that should be taught in
schools like financial literacy
investing and luckily in my high school
yeah we needed at least two years of
financial literacy classes yes so
but you know when you have half of the
country not even being able to read at a
sixth grade level
it's gonna get kind of hard for us to
have
uh understanding of both reading and
money like
i think that
one reason why that statistic that you
shared is so low amongst women
is um
you like spark something it's because
that
we
it's shared more like financial literacy
and correct me if i'm wrong it's shared
more with
people who are wealthy already wealthy
yeah already wealthy and that typically
comes from the caucasian community and
it's something that isn't well i'm
talking about like women only in
conclusion yeah that's what i'm saying
like okay it's taught you have to bring
up that intersection what i'm saying
like even if it's like the wealthy
people have that knowledge like they
um like it's half women like
yeah but i'm saying just like the
dynamic of whatever community you come
from i don't know statistics yeah
yeah yeah from this community that
community but it's
very um
it's not talked about yeah it's not
talked about it as much and i can
understand why that would be
low because of just the dynamics from do
you feel like the the internet though is
kind of the great equalizer because you
have access to all this information that
like like you can you can look up like a
billionaire giving someone financial
advice yeah i do think that
you can access anything and everything
on the internet but if it's not
something that you grew up with you've
been taught like this is important like
financial literacy you need to
understand it you're not going to look
it up on your own i just from what i've
seen i don't think it's like a community
thing like i think women just spend
money on like clothes and like like like
more like looks yeah like like i think
women just have worse spending habits
than yeah and i do think that and i
think think has been
made possibly
as well yeah like men that we are the
ones who are going to consume this kind
of stuff how often do you see forever 21
talking about the men's section
yeah our whole media is like marketed
towards women everything you see is like
for a female audiences into a corner
except for this show
tell me something yeah
yeah it becomes an issue in society can
i say
yeah go ahead i
disagree with that to an extent
let's not get damn she just [ __ ]
shooting me left there right
you're on my left right now
she said left and right so
[Music]
hold on um i think i disagree with that
to an extent i can't like personally i'm
not remember i care about how i look but
i think this was my passion for fashion
right mm-hmm they're funny but that's a
personal thing
but i think in terms there's a lot of
guys males that are very invested in how
they look a lot more than women whereas
women can think it's wrong statistically
you're wrong
you're thinking of
exceptions the role you're thinking
you're wrong people are like the
exceptions
yeah exceptions
yeah men will make a big purchase
as
well it's how you like what you want as
a person as well yeah like for example
like you can just want to dress because
you want to dress up there's a there's
an artist like
she's not in the fashion business she's
actually an artist
but she's just plays about in fashion
for forever
yes it does it's very nice they have
great graphic tees
that actually play around in fashion for
fun that's not their career but they get
a kick out of it yeah because they like
it
yeah i know but like like again remember
when we're having these conversations
we're talking about in general we're not
talking about like you want because why
does your your mind go to a specific
it's like you want to argue because
you're like oh this one person is an
exception to the stereotype because but
a stereotype
[Music]
audiences us fashion is fully rooted in
women yeah yeah like we touch
accessories right
exactly
because they know we gonna spend that
was the only thing that we could do at
some point also and also i think that
the society
i think that the main thing is like
women
i don't know the statistic of how many
women are in the world how many men but
typically sex cell and women are
sexualized and so that's why they gear
tourists like they know they're going to
buy the stuff they know if they have if
they see a woman wearing something that
they're looking and this the women are
going to be like but are they sexualized
for men or for women if women make 80
percent of consumer purchasing
historically like let's look like
historically like
when
like when women wore corsets and they
were right little right things that you
think
that was because they were being brought
out into society to find a husband and
they were being sexualized so i feel
like that's also a point to be made like
they like when they had money it's like
oh well let's spend this on a dress but
again gaby but what is that like what
does that have to do with us today today
because it's morphed into where it
trickles down to where we are
but i just i just i just i just believe
in personal responsibility like if you
have bad credit and you were born in
2020 like that's your own fault no it's
not it's not that's true that's true no
no no but it's not it what it's about
like there's a certain standard in
society for women of how we should be
and we're kind of like taught that not
saying it's verbal right that's pushed
on us from it's okay
it's a form of priming
i have a teammate that i played
volleyball with her mother would not let
her leave the house without her nails
done her hair done an outfit and now i
[ __ ]
if that's the case why are statistically
the majority of women overweight
like if that's the case if we're forced
to look a certain way right and that's
that that's the standard right that's
the like standard then like i don't and
men don't accept that there's a lot of
things that go into
being overweight and if we go back to
what we talked about
first about toxic relationship and just
like just stuff that we go through
emotionally
i think that
women i'm not saying that men don't go
through things emotionally but i feel
like women go through more emotionally
and have things right well we're more
more emotional yeah yeah and from that
the
the easiest thing to resort to is eating
and
just being
um well they changed our food to comfort
from the 50s yeah and so i think that
that may be the one the main thing
is just like it's just comfort finding
comfort and food food's always going to
comfort you no matter what
bad food and
i think that that is one thing not
canceling out like men don't go through
nothing and we all yeah yeah right but
it's just like that's one thing from
just what i've seen and what i've just
like so you think the majority of like
women being overweight is from emotional
like trauma
like
growing up i was a stick like i was
stick then i was underweight i got put
on medication to gain weight because i
was unhealthily underweight right
and so i and when i was skinny it was
like all i wanted to do was have curves
like all i wanted was to have an ass
like that's all i could think about
i gained weight and then it's like the
the whole it's like the opposite right
and it's like i always felt like i was
trying to fit into a
standard it was i could never fit into i
could never just be
because but it's also that's personal
on me because it's like well it's
interesting because i would look at you
like as the like you you're you're
stunning to be honest
like like that's what i'm saying but
it's interesting because like you you
i feel like you have to know you're
hotter than like most girls right but
like are you respectful as also being
six three right like growing up i was
[ __ ] bullied because i hit 6'3 when i
was 13.
have you ever watched that one look at
those movies
oh those are the worst but like but like
i feel it like literally it's funny when
you say like lebron james because like
when i was in middle school like people
would be like oh kobe bryant lebron
james
watched all right you say that in the
tall girl movie sasquatch and it's like
that has an effect on you and like
people would always make comments to me
like i was like 120 pounds and i was 6'3
like i was a
like
it was
like i looked like a skeleton right and
then it's like all i wanted was this one
was the curves yes
but you showed me pictures you were
curvy yeah up to a point yeah like i
gained a lot of muscle right but then i
got on medication right gained a lot of
weight and then i was like
well do you just want to be well do you
do you feel like that's society or
that's like an internal
yeah society is either like you're
right
internal
either a good curvy or you're you're
there's no nasty thing but it's
interesting skinny and there's bad stuff
but it's interesting because i like to
me it's all like like i think women are
meaner to women than men are to be
honest girls are yes like girls are
putting us away but also the part where
women are more critical comes from their
insecurities
oh yeah projection rejection
women are very generous but that doesn't
i know but it doesn't make it okay
like women are meaner to women like most
guys aren't you know like men swipe on
right on like 50 percent of women like
most men aren't that rhythm most most no
i'm saying most men aren't that picky
like don't they also
they're attracted most
well most most men are attracted to like
like a lot of women like it's the if
you're getting rejected by guys they're
in a very small percentage of men like
10 to 15 percent of men even like they
say um 20 of men have access to 80 of
the women so the reason that we hate men
is because we're all effing the same
ones yeah
like if you want a guy that's six foot
in the top 15 percent of math literally
yeah yeah income
yeah yeah and so i'm saying the majority
of men aren't picky and so so women
because we're competing for those men
like they they tear at each other
because they think
we little each other because like from
example like
okay personally yeah never say there's
not a man that i've wanted that i
haven't got personally yeah let them
know
that this must be nice
there's been men that i've rejected that
have been like well i don't want your
fat ass anyways oh yeah oh yeah i'm
saying so it's like but like that [ __ ]
like sticks with you like you know yeah
it's like but you wanted me but now
you're calling me this why are you
feeling so hard for the question as soon
as i rejected it
yeah i try to try to make it one at a
time just so like the i've just had
comments that they can't hear because
there's too many people talking
yeah yeah i get what you're saying okay
but like you know like
that [ __ ] like sticks with a person
right like like i remember there was one
time i was at cal berkeley and this guy
was hollering at me
and i was like please [ __ ] off like he
was such a little frat boy he's like
i don't want your fat ass anyways this
was four years ago i was skinnier than i
was like 15 pounds lighter than like i
you know what i'm saying yeah
but like that [ __ ] like sticks with a
person like well he thought i was fat
like so it's like well the girls do like
i don't know girls kind of like are
worse almost behind each other's backs
well that's true it's just not to our
face we're more we're more behind the
back that part is [ __ ] yeah even in
front of their face girls are very spicy
but it's it's more sub like shady you
know men
men can't even see the looks that girls
give us at the bar and you know exactly
what looks like the the shade men can't
see it
because um there's a biological
reasoning behind it but basically like
because women were like gatherers and
like we were more with the kids
biologically we pick up on other
people's emotions better so it's
i don't know but i do have a yeah go
ahead go ahead a question what